So now that we understand the flow of information of where these blueprints come from and are processed,
let's go over some core concepts in Unreal Engine which will help you on your journey.
The first thing that we need to consider is that a blueprint is an asset that adds functionality on top of an existing gameplay class.
So again, when we're talking about the parent and child classes, we're always adding more functionality to an existing class.
And we define the content and functionality of a C++ class via the visual studio editing,
whereas in blueprints we can edit it directly in the engine.
So the example that you see on your screen here is all under the hood C++,
but it's just a very visual representation of the information.
So here we have a timeline on the left hand side which we will get to in a few minutes here.
We see that the timeline is updating to some kind of set rotation,
which in this example is a door, so we will open a door.
And the rotation that you give the door is based on this lerp at the bottom which is the green function,
a lerp rotator, which essentially is looking at the A and B value and lerping between the A and B value.
So in this example we're going from a zero rotation in Z to a 90 degree rotation in Z which causes the door to open.
It's just a very nice visual workflow here.
All blueprints are based on C++, so it's just a very visual way of thinking about the C++ that's running under the hood.
The blueprint script visualization method will be persistent in many of the subeditors of UE5.
So as we get deeper into Unreal Engine and as we see that blueprint is this glue that holds together
the Unreal Engine through different interfaces that might be in animation graphs,
it might be in character control graphs, it might be in larger level graphs.
Again, not to worry about the specific context of what I'm referring to here.
However, it's useful to know that blueprints are used in many different areas of Unreal Engine
and it's useful to understand these core components because they are persistent across most of the editor.
The common classes that you'll be looking for here are part of the gameplay framework in Unreal Engine.
So they're how you create players and controllers and game rules in the game.
Creating a new blueprint will require you to pick up a parent to be the base of a new blueprint class.
So when we create a new class, and again we'll go ahead and do this in a couple of minutes here,
but you'll be picking a parent class. When we're talking about things inherited from a previous class,
it's useful to know where that parent class comes from.
So before you create any kind of blueprint, you'll be asked who is your parent class
because that comes with a whole bunch of information that Unreal Engine has provided to you
that you then don't need to recode yourself.
You get a bunch of set default characteristics, which again we can override and manipulate
as we spoke about in the previous slides, but it gives you a really good starting point.
So the most common ones here are actor, pawn, character, player controller, game mode, base,
an actor component, and a scene component.
And we'll get into these and you'll be more familiar by the end of the course about what does what here.
So the different types of blueprints, and once we've picked a parent class,
we can pick a whole series of different blueprints based on the relative functionality that we need.
You might have level blueprints, which if you're working on a game in a specific level,
you might have some custom scripting, a scripted event or something like this,
that would be a level blueprint.
You've got data only blueprints, which can be enumerators or structures
that you can see on the list on the bottom right-hand of your screen there.
We have interfaces, which we touched upon in a couple of these training videos,
but interfaces are essentially a blueprint communication device.
So it says you can communicate from one blueprint to another via an interface.
And the macro and function libraries, which if anyone's familiar with C++,
you can create macros and functions inside a blueprint that house gameplay code.